cette semaine notre série fabriqués au
canada fait un arrêt à laval où se
trouve le dernier fabricant de tables de
billard au pays
le propriétaire de canada billard met
toujours l'accent sur un travail inspiré
des méthodes d'autrefois
valérie michael aubin ce n'est pas
d'hier que l'on joue au billard
jeunes et moins jeunes s'adonnent à ce
passe-temps depuis des lustres
si ce loisir a traversé les époques
le temps a eu raison de toutes les
entreprises qui fabriquent ces tables de
jeu au pays tout sauf canada billard à
laval qui se targue d'être la dernière à
concevoir ses tables de billard ici j'ai
72 heures plus tard car les chiffres
parce que j'aime j'aime ce que je fais
au début des années 70 michel lemire
possède des tables de billard payante
dans des bars et des tavernes lorsqu'il
doit remplacer les tapis et les
baguettes les manufacturiers refuse de
lui vendre directement leurs produits
ils le réfère à des détaillants tels
qu'un modus vous savez fabricant table
de billard ou alors c'est pas tombée
dans l'oreille d'un saut j'ai fondé la
compagnie canada bjork canada billard ne
fabrique pourtant pas de table à cette
époque mais vend plus tous les produits
de la réputée compagnie américaine
brunswick randonnée l'onp l'indécision
mind arrêté de fabriquer sont véreux
d'abord et puis ont été fabriqués h m et
c'est à ce moment là moi que j'ai mes
propres produits c'est donc dans les
années 80 qu'il se lance dans la
production avec un seul critère en tête
offrir des tables de qualité
je n'avais pas beaucoup de modèles ça a
été graduellement
comment à ses parfums de modèles et
aujourd'hui on a peut-être une
cinquantaine
la fabrication est faite par des
ébénistes et des apprentis à partir de
matériaux achetés au canada et ici on
fabrique beaucoup selon les vieilles
méthodes comme certains fabriquer 200 du
vieux mais aussi du très moderne
l'équipement de pointe fait maintenant
partie des outils travail en 2002 son
entreprise et en flore y sente michel
lemire décide de doubler le nombre
d'employés et sa capacité de production
c'est aussi à ce moment qu'il décide de
maintenir sa production au québec les
produits chinois qui intéressera marché
c'était le premier gros défi
jeholet fin comme la plupart des
compagnies mannala chinois n'aimait plus
fabriquer mes projets et puis on avait
un nom avait respecté le nom des
canettes de bière qui était très
important l'anglais pauvres en des
produits qui n'étaient pas de qualité
canada billard vinci table partout au
pays et même à l'étranger
les modèles d'entrée de gamme vendu à
1600 $ sont les plus populaires les plus
coûteuses dépasse les 10 mille dollars
l'entreprise lavalloise s'est lancé à la
conquête du marché américain il y a
quelques années pour se démarquer de la
concurrence
elle a conçu des tables de billard qui
sont aussi des tables de salle à manger
le produit unique en amérique du nord
représente le quart des ventes de la
compagnie la fabrication de tables de
billard n'a plus de secret pour monsieur
lemire
qu'en est il du jeu
la question qui tue est revu bon au
billard j'ai déjà été bon ici valérie
michaela bègue du canada montréal